[Music]
all right up next is eric in columbia
south carolina eric how can we help
hey guys how are you we are having a
blast what are you doing
i got a question about um well i'm
trying to get out of debt i started um
listening to you guys and dave about a
month ago and my grandfather and my
father are very big fans of you guys
so i'm trying to follow you know what
they say and also listen to what you and
guys stop on the podcast um
so i paid my credit card off and then
i'm trying to get out of a car loan
and i know the used car market is
obviously hot right now but every time i
go to a different dealership the value
of the car seems to go
backwards instead of forward
so my question is how do i get out of a
car loan that i'm in negative
so you're upside down on this thing
what's the loan amount
uh 48 000 whoa
what kind of car is this
it's a truck it's a audi q7 wow what
year
uh 2018
2018 how many miles
uh i think 55 000
and what did they say they'd give uh
give you for it at the dealership
so we went to
one a little like three weeks ago and it
was at 40
000 was the trade-in offer that they
gave then we went back um
yesterday and now it's down to 38. well
why are we doing something to another
one what about if it wasn't that
fun to pay the difference
okay but i'm saying what if you didn't
do a trade-in what if you just sold it
privately let's say how much could you
get for it
uh probably 45 or so because they're
always going to give you less for the
trade-in amount so i'm going to do some
some a lot more research have you
checked carvana and vroom and some of
these online companies
uh no one will have charge that's i
guess reasonable is carmax he doesn't
have to george because i've done it
right here
okay i pulled up just a little search
edmonds is one source there's many
sources
in the columbia south carolina area and
you've got a range here you said you
think you've got 55 000 you're not 100
sure uh but we've got one q7 here that's
got 61 000 miles on it 38 990. uh you've
got another one at the
let's see
whoa one at 53 it's got 42 000 miles on
it so they're asking 53 4 for this
uh so just doing a quick uh quick survey
here's another one uh
45 000 miles 44.9 so i know that's a
little bit less miles than what you've
got here but i think george is right
private market is what i'd be looking at
yeah how much money do you have eric
just savings checking
um
about
six thousand dollars of everything okay
so you got six grand i just paid yeah
but just paid off uh six thousand
dollars in credit card debt awesome so
you paid off six 000 and you have 6 000
in the bank
correct awesome well that's a great
place to be because you're going to owe
the difference
if you went and sold it in order to get
out of the loan correct
so the fact that you have some money is
great so what i'm doing i'm going to get
top dollar for for that audi and then
with whatever money you need to pay the
difference you pay the difference and
call it a stupid tax and you move on
with your life and then you obviously
need a car so my hope is that right
let's say you can
you owe maybe three grand difference to
pay off the loan well you still have
three grand left so i'm gonna sock away
a thousand for the emergency fund and
i'm gonna get
the
junkiest car that is the opposite of the
car you're driving right now
and you're gonna drive that until you
can save up enough money to upgrade to a
four thousand dollar car you're gonna
sell that one and do the same thing and
eventually you're gonna trade up it to
where you have a decent car and then one
day you're gonna have an amazing car but
right now we've gotta focus on getting
out of this pile of debt and get you a
fully funded emergency fund and get you
investing so that you have some control
on the future eric you can do this can't
you
yes sir i mean how's that gonna feel to
get that off your shoulders all that
debt even though it's not gonna be fun
how's it gonna
feel feel like
everything's off my shoulders come on
man what's your income eric
uh 72 000. oh there we go so we can save
up some money and you said that's your
only debt left is the car
i got i just purchased a house so that's
on there too so you got the mortgage but
other than that your consumer don't work
each other on the mortgage that's it
that's it awesome all right man you're
going to be in good shape once we get
rid of this car but do your research i'm
checking everywhere i'm going private
sale on facebook and craigslist and
autotrader checking vroom and carvana
seeing who's going to pay me the most
money
and now's the time to do it we are we're
seeing reports of
car manufacturers getting angry at
dealers this was a major headline over
last weekend because car dealers are
selling cars four five six seven
thousand dollars above msrp
and and and that's one negative of this
kind of bloated kind of inflation driven
market on auto you know the auto
industry but
we're also seeing high value for used
cars now is the time to do this if
you're upside down now's the time on the
ramsey plan it's a great time to get out
of your car it really is